hi i'm emily hi i'm cam hi my name is
carly hi my name is chase
hey guys i'm melinda hey my name is
kayla
hey my name is marvin my name is nathan
we are the cast
of too hot to handle and today we are
taking a questionnaire of buzzfeed
and we are going to see if we can
survive
too hot to handle retreat without losing
any money
so we're going to go ahead and jump into
the first question
what is your number one vice so we got
coffee
gambling wine chocolate
designer clothes or sex i'm going i'm
going to design your clothes all the way
wasn't it you asking every night if we
could get an additional glass of wine
yeah that would be alcoholic exactly
nathan what's yours i don't want to
sound awful
because i've actually got better but it
used to be gambling i knew you're gonna
say that i bet your mom is really proud
marvin what was yours mine you know i'm
french so it's
wine oh same with me i'm gonna do coffee
because sometimes
a good cup of coffee is better than sex
i'm gonna pick sex okay i'm straight i'm
torn between coffee or sex
uh i love coffee but i love sex as well
so um
laughing's gonna be sex why do you fall
it stinks pick another reality tv star
to share uh
too hot to handle bed with so we have
harry kevin tan chloe christelle or
lauren
mine's harry mine's lauren she's hot
i'm gonna go with chloe oh my god she
was hitting on you
totally ashley harry let's be honest
gotta go chloe i'm going chloe
yeah i'm gonna take prachelle i don't
know that chick but like oh she's
awesome
she's hot i'm gonna go with harry it's a
toss-up between chloe and chris and
honestly
like i've seen the beds that we have so
i'll probably just take the both of them
and i'll just squeeze them between
oh done deal i'm gonna go with crochet
because
i don't really know who it is and that's
more exciting so
lana has allowed you to go on a date in
the house pick a sexy food
to share so you got chocolate cherries
bananas whipped cream oysters or
strawberries
i'm definitely going with it with the
cherries for sure
i would say oysters i feel like
strawberries would get caught in your
teeth and oysters i just love them
i'm going with strawberries classic any
of y'all ever used whipped cream it's
the worst like it the idea of it is
fantastic to like squirt a little bit
onto nipples but
then you just stuff it's so sticky i
would say whipped cream but it's
actually got a funny smell to it if
you've ever used whipped cream in the
bedroom
it's actually not as nice as it is it
seems i think i'm going to go
strawberries
yeah i'll pick strawberries too me too
also
strawberry oh i'm probably going to go
with cherries
i like i like a good cherry uh-oh your
partner in the house is laying it on
thick how do you respond you put a stop
to it immediately and leave the room
you cuddle but nothing more you seek in
a little kiss
it's only three grand you full on make
out
maybe a couple other things you succumb
to temptation but it was worth it
or shh i don't kiss and tell what's it
gonna be
i mean with my track record i probably
would go with this sneaky little kissing
73k
i'm gonna go with the sh i don't please
and tell because i
i'd rather just deny stuff and let let
lana figure out for me
i'm saying sure i don't kiss and tell
because i probably will kiss
yeah i said cuddle but nothing more
chase what did you put follow the rules
oh chase you're so lame like get over it
uh you already know guys you should come
to the temptation
i'm ashamed of my answer you full on
make out and maybe
maybe a couple other things i had a girl
baby which song
gets you in the mood s m by rihanna pony
by
genuine sex on fire by kings leon
thinking about you
by frank ocean whap by cardi b and megan
stallion
slave for you by britney spears oh yeah
i know the answer all the way
right in my pony
he's gonna be thinking about you i chose
the same thing
i'm thinking [ __ ] sex on fire for me i
like key and
leon kayla what's yours s m by rihanna
oh spicy i'm a subtle kind of r b smooth
guy so i'm going
thinking about you by frank ocean mine's
whack hands down
love that shoe what is your favorite
part of sex
the day itself foreplay
the moment of anticipation before it
begins
the you know sex part the post coitus
cuddles
or knocking the heck out afterwards i
need the option to call the uber right
after
mine's the foreplay i'm gonna go for the
you know
sex part i choose foreplay yeah i go for
play i'm full play i need my nipple
i need my ass laughs i'm saying
anticipation
really i'm gonna go with uh the sex
itself
yes i will go follow the post coach's
cuddles
last but not least which of these things
excites you the most
whips blindfolds handcuffs candles
gags or ice cubes i'm going to go
handcuffs i quite like handcuffs i'm
going glad
i clicked handcuffs but i want to put
candles i'm going to go with the candles
y'all don't like ice cubes like rubbed
all over you no
i picked blindfolds you picked blindfold
too marvin yeah
oh no i lost the most money i've lost
the most money
mine says you lost a little bit of money
you lost a little bit of money
any money i didn't break any rules one
is proud of me
let's go mine says you lost the most
money i lost the most money apparently
this game's a fix how can we both lose
the most money you rigged this
thank you so much buzzfeed and guys be
sure to watch two at the handle
on netflix
you